The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So today
we're going to continue
our course on the graph theory.
It's going to be a mixture
of all kinds of topics.
We first start off
with Euler tour,
and then we get
into directed graphs
and cover the definitions.
And we'll talk about
a special type, which
are called tournament graphs.
And we'll do a whole
bunch of proofs,
and hopefully you will all
contribute to make this work
and think about how to do this.
So next week we will
continue with graph theory,
and we will discuss
a very special type.
We will use directed graphs
in communication networks.
And on Thursday, we'll actually
use these special types
of graphs that we'll talk
about in a moment, DAGs.
So let's talk about Euler tour.
Euler, a famous mathematician,
he asked the question
like-- he lived in Konigsberg.
And there were seven bridges.
He was wondering, can you
traverse all the bridges
exactly once.
So he would start walking and
try to cross all those bridges.
And apparently this little
islands in sort of the river
as well, and so on.
So how can you do that?
This is actually the
birth of graph theory.
And this particular
problem is named after him.
So what is an Euler tour?
It's actually defined
as a special walk.
It's a walk that traverses
every edge exactly once.
So it turns out the you
can actually characterize
these types of graphs.
So we are talking here
about undirected graph,
so continuation of last time.
So the edges that we
consider have no direction.
We'll come back to
that in a moment.
We will start
defining those later.
So Euler tour is a walk that
traverses every edge exactly
once.
And at the same time,
it's also a tour.
So that means that it
actually starts and finishes
at the same vertex.
Now it turns out that
undirected graphs,
the graphs that we've
been talking about,
those that Euler tours can
be easily characterized.
And that's the theorem that
we're going to prove next.
The theorem states
that actually,
if a connected graph
has an Euler tour,
if and only if, every vertex
of the graph has even degree.
So that's a very nice and
simple and straightforward
characterization.
So how can we prove this?
So let's have a look.
So first of all, we have an
if and only if statement.
So we need to prove
two directions.
We need to proof that if I
have a connected graph that
has an Euler tour, I need to
show that every vertex has
even degree.
And also the reverse-- if I have
a graph for which every vertex
has even degree, I need to
show that it has an Euler tour.
So the proof consists
of two parts.
So let's first do
this implication,
where we assure that
we have connected
graph that has an Euler tour.
So assume we have a graph.
So we have G with the
vertex at V, edge is at E,
and it has an Euler tour.
So what does it mean?
Well, it's really
means that we can walk
from some start vertex, V0.
We can go all the way around to
V1, and some more, and so on,
to V, say, k minus 1.
And then end vertex is the
same as the start vertex.
So we have a walk that goes
all around the whole graph.
So every edge in this
walk are exactly the edges
that are in the graph.
And each edge in the graph
is offered exactly once.
So what does it mean?
So let's write
this down actually.
So since every edge is
traversed once-- every edge in E
is traversed once-- what
can we conclude from that?
Can we say something about,
given such as walk of length k,
what can we say about the
number of edges, for example?
What can we say about the
degree of the vertices?
Because that's what you
want to show, right?
You want to show that every
vertex has even degree.
Does anyone know how
to go ahead here?
So we know that every
single edge in E
is referred ones
within this whole walk.
So what kind of
properties can we derive?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's true.
PROFESSOR: Maybe someone
else can pick up here.
So every vertex that I
have here, I will enter it.
But I also leave it.
So if I see a vertex
in here, I can
see at least two
contributing edges
that are coming from this.
AUDIENCE: Then you know
that that note has at least
degree 2, but it
can't be more than 2
because otherwise that
would be the endpoint.
PROFESSOR: Ah.
But is it true though
that-- so for example,
this particular note here may
repeat itself somewhere else.
I only have a condition
on the Euler tour
that every edge
occurs exactly ones.
So how could I formally
sort of continue to prove?
AUDIENCE: Well, it will
intersect itself again,
and you'll leave again
and it will still
have the even number.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's true.
That's right.
Any other additions?
AUDIENCE: You can define
the number of edges
that it will test by
how many you enter it,
so the number of
edges that it has
is twice the number
of [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's correct. [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] traverse
once, then every time you enter
a node you have to leave it.
So you can say that
you're never going
to leave a node for a node that
it already left for from there.
And you're never going to enter
from a node you already entered
from or left to from there.
So that's how you can say
that you're only going
to increment your degree by 2.
PROFESSOR: That's true.
So what he's
essentially saying is
that every edge as
I start to count
here, in this particular tour,
well they're all different.
So they all counts towards
a degree of the node.
So everything that you have
been saying is right on.
What we can conclude here is
that if you look at a vertex,
say vertex U-- for example,
somewhere over here-- well,
it may repeat itself over here.
And it has an incoming and
outgoing edge, incoming
and outgoing edge.
And I may have it
somewhere else,
but say it's just at those two.
Well, I know that all
the edges are different.
So I can clearly count this now.
I can say that the
degree of U must
be equal to the number
of times that U actually
appears in this tour.
So in the tour from V0
all the way to Vk minus 1.
And then I have to
multiply times 2.
And what I said, it's exactly
what you have been saying,
all the edges occur exactly
once of the whole graph.
So I just count the number
of times I see U in here.
I come the number of edges that
go into it and leave from it.
Well, that's twice times
the number of times
that U actually
appears in this tour.
So this implication is
pretty straightforward
because now we actually note
that the degree of U is even.
So that's great.
So let's talk about
the other implication
and see whether we can find
a trick to make that happen.
So what do we need
to start off with?
Well, now we have to assume that
every vertex has even degree.
So let's write this down.
So say we have the graph.
And for this graph
we actually issue
that the degree of
every vertex V is even.
Well, what can we do?
Well, this is sort
of creative trick,
so let me just continue here.
So what we have is if you
start to consider a walk, W,
that touches, say, a lot
of vertices in such a way
that W is actually
the longest walk.
So that's often what
you do in graph theory.
You think about, say,
the shortest path
or whatever with a certain
property, or the longest walk,
or whatever with a
certain property.
So that's what
you're doing here.
So let W be the longest walk.
And well, we want to prove
something about an Euler tour.
An Euler tour has a
very specific property
that all the edges
occur only once.
So it makes sense
to look at walks
in which all the edges of
which it walks are unique,
are occurring only once.
So we're interested in the
longest walk that traverses
no edge more than once.
So that's important.
Now, let's think about
this a little bit.
So the first property that you
may want to consider it-- you
really want to show that W
is going to be an Euler tour.
That's what we're going
to try to prove here.
So the first thing
we may want to show
is that actually
it goes all around.
So V0 is equal to Vk.
That will be great
if we can do this.
So we want to show
that this is true.
So what would happen if
this would not be the case?
So suppose these two would
not be equal to one another.
Well, actually, I'm skipping
a little bit ahead here
in the proof, I notice.
So this will be the conclusion
of another observation.
So let me start with
the first observation.
So first of all, let us
consider this end node over
here, this end vertex, Vk.
Now if there is an edge that
is not covered in this walk--
and I can lengthen
the walk, right?
So if I have, say,
another edge, which
looks like Vk, an edge
from Vk to some U, where
this edge is not in the walk.
Or the other one
is not in the walk.
Well, it doesn't matter in
an indirect graph, of course.
So if this is not in the
walk, then what can I do?
I can just lengthen it, right?
I can just say V0 goes
to V1 goes to Vk goes
to U. Now I have a longer walk.
And that's a contradiction.
So I know that all the edges
in which Vk is participating
are actually
covered by the walk.
So that's a great property.
So let's write this down.
So all edges that
are incident to Vk
are actually used--
traversed-- in the walk, W.
So now let's have
a look whether we
can show that it's a walk
that goes all the way around.
So let's try to
prove this statement.
So let me repeat this over here.
So what we want to show
is that Vk equals V0.
So given this statement,
do you have any idea
how we could
possibly prove this,
also given what we have
been doing over here?
Suppose this would not
be the case, right?
So suppose the start and
the end node in this walk
are not equal to one another.
So what can we do here?
So maybe there's
some suggestions?
I already had you once.
Maybe someone else?
AUDIENCE: It has to
attach to another vertex.
And you know that all
the degrees are even.
So it means that Vk
must attach to V0.
PROFESSOR: So what you're
saying, first of all,
is that if this would
not be the case, then
you know that the
degrees must be even.
But suppose this
would not be the case.
That would mean actually that
the degree would be odd, right?
OK.
So let's think about
that a little bit.
So let's write this down.
So otherwise the
Vk has odd degree.
But the only node has odd
degree in this particular walk,
W. So that's what we do now.
Because we really
consider this walk.
So we see that if I have
V0 unequal to Vk and Vk
maybe repeated in this
walk a number of times,
each time it is repeated
it has an incoming
and an outgoing edge.
And all these edges are
different because they do not
occur more than once.
So whenever Vk enters in
this middle part over here--
it's partaking over here--
it gives an even contribution
to the number of
edges in this walk,
and it has one extra
incoming edge over here.
So if V0 is not
equal to Vk, we will
have an odd degree
of edges in W,
in which Vk is participating.
So now we can go ahead and
we can have a look over here
because we just showed here that
all the edges incident to Vk
are actually used in W. So
we can now conclude that this
means that Vk also
has odd degree in G
because all the edges in G,
in which Vk is participating,
are actually used in the walk.
So I hope that is clear.
So let's write this down.
So we'll use the first
statement over here, so by 1.
We have that Vk has
odd degree in G.
And now we come to
what you were saying.
We have assumed over here
that the degree is even.
So this cannot be the case,
so that's a contradiction.
So we know that the otherwise
situation cannot occur.
So we know that Vk
must be equal to V0.
So that's proving
that we actually have
a walk that goes all around.
Now, we are not yet done.
Because why would
this be an Euler tour?
For an Euler tour,
we really want
that every single
edge that G has
is actually used in the tour.
So we need much more.
So let's use this board.
So suppose that W is
not an Euler tour.
We're going to
use contradiction.
But we already have shown
this particular property,
so we can use this.
So suppose W is
not an Euler tour.
Well, we know that
G is connected.
So that's a good
thing because that
means that if it is
not an Euler tour,
there is an edge that is
not used in W, in the walk,
but it is incident to some
vertex that is used in W.
So this is where the
connectivity here
comes in play.
Now let us call
this edge-- so let
U-Vi be this particular edge.
So U is not used in
the walk-- well, it's
maybe used in the walk, but the
edge is not used in the walk.
And Vi is part of the walk.
So what can we do here?
So does anybody see
what we could do here?
Can we somehow get
a contradiction?
So when we started
out here, we actually
assumed that W is the longest
walk in which the edges do not
occur more than once.
Can we create a longer
walk by simply using this?
Now, notice that we did
prove that V0 goes all around
to Vk, and so on.
So can we find a longer walk
that uses this extra edge?
Any ideas?
What would happen if we, for
example, started a walk with U?
Let's see how that
would work out.
We can have U. We walk to Vi.
Well, let's just simply
start walking all around.
So essentially we have Vi
over here and U over here.
So we could do is we can
start walking like this
and then end over here.
And notice we have
used one extra edge.
So we get a longer walk.
So we go to Vi plus 1,
and we go all the way
up to Vk, which is equal to V0.
And then we go up to V1,
all the way up to Vi.
This is a longer walk.
And therefore we
have a contradiction.
And now the proof is
finished because that means
that this assumption was wrong.
So W actually is an Euler tour.
So now we have shown the
existence of an Euler tour,
and that was the other
direction of the theorem.
So let's now start with a
new topic on directed graphs.
And later on, we will talk
about how Hamiltonian paths.
And these are
different from an Euler
tour in that in an Euler tour,
every edge is used exactly
once.
In a Hamiltonian path, we
will have that every vertex
is used exactly once.
So we'll do that a bit later.
So what are directed graphs?
Directed graphs are
graphs where we have edges
that have a specific direction.
So we can walk from one
vertex to the other.
Let me just depict an example.
For example, we could have
something that looks like this.
We have V1.
We have V2, V3.
We may have an edge that
goes like this with an arrow.
We use arrows in this case.
I can go to V2 and V3.
From V2 I may be able to go
to V3, and from V3 to V2.
So this will be a directed
graph, as an example.
We also call these digraphs.
And as you can see, we may have
an edge that goes from V2 to V3
and also one that
goes from V3 to V2.
So these are two separate edges.
So every edge has a direction.
And we usually say that
if we have an edge that
points from V2 to, say, V3,
then we call this the tail
and over here we have the head.
So this is some notation
that you may use.
We also have now
a different notion
for the degree of a vertex
because we have different types
of edges, essentially.
Take, for example, V2.
You have incoming edges
and outgoing edges.
So that's why
we're going to talk
about an indegree
and an outdegree.
So, for example, the indegree
of V2 is equal to, well, I
have one, two incoming edges.
And the outdegree of V2 is
actually something different.
It's just one outgoing edge.
So this is equal to 1.
So this is some notation.
So let's talk about walks.
Let's figure out
where we can enumerate
walks in a directed
graph and compute those.
So how many walks
do I have, say,
of length k that go exactly
from, say, V1 to V3.
How can I compute this?
So I'd like to introduce
adjacency matrices.
You've probably
seen them before.
But let's go over this once
more because induction is also
important.
So let's do the theorem.
So the theorem is this.
Suppose we have a graph.
And suppose it has end nodes.
And we have the
vertices V1 up to Vn.
And now we let the matrix that
contains the entries aij denote
the adjacency matrix for G.
And what does it mean?
It's actually means
that in this case,
we say that aij is equal
to 1 if we actually
have an edge that
goes from Vi to Vj--
so this is an edge-- and
0 if this is not the case.
So this is the adjacency matrix.
And now we can state something
about the number of directed
walks in a directed graph.
So it turns out
that this is easily
computed by taking powers
of the adjacency matrix.
Let aij with the
superscript k be
equal to the number of
directed walks of length k
that go from Vi to Vj.
So you want to compute
this and it turns out
that-- wait a minute.
So what did I do here?
So actually let p
kij be the number
of directed walks of length
k from phi i to phi j.
Then what you can show is
if you look at matrix A
to the power k, this
actually is the matrix that
contains all these numbers.
So let me give a few examples.
So let's take the
matrix over here.
Look at this ajc matrix,
take a few powers
and see what happens.
So the matrix looks like this.
If you just label the rows
by, say, V1, V2, and V3.
The columns by V1, V2, and V3.
Well, V1 has an edge to V1.
V1 has an edge to V2
and also one to V3.
V2 has only one edge to
V3, so we have zeros here.
And we have this.
So this is the matrix A.
For example, if you
compute a squared.
So how do we do this?
How many of you know about
matrix multiplication?
Everybody knows?
Well anyway, so let's assume
that you do know actually.
So that's pretty simple.
So you take the column.
You take the inners product
with the first row, and so on.
And you can easily
compute this otherwise
you may want to do
it yourself later on.
And you get this
particular matrix.
And, for example,
a to the power of 3
is something very similar--
1, 3, 3, 0, 0, 1, 0, 1, 0.
Well, it turns out that
if you look at this graph
and we, for example, want
to know the number of walks
of length 3 that go
from V1 to, say, V2,
let's see whether we
can see those over here.
Well, if I travel from
V1 to V2 in three steps,
I can go like this.
I can go one, two, three.
So that's one option.
I can go one, and
another one time,
so it's a second
step, and three.
I can also go directly over here
and go back here, and back over
here.
So it turns out that's
I can compute this.
So how do we prove this?
We'll use induction.
And the steps are
pretty straightforward.
So let's first
define, because we
want to prove that kth power
of a is equal to that matrix
up there, where all the entries
represent the number of walks.
So let's say that aijk,
that this denote the i jth
entry in a to the power k.
And you want to show that
this number is actually
equal to pijk for
all the entries.
So if you're going
to use induction,
it makes sense to assume that
the theorem is true for k.
So the induction hypothesis
could be something like this.
The theorem is true for k.
And this is really
the same as stating
that all these entries
for all i and j-- aij
is equal to the pijk.
So this is what
you want to prove.
And this is pretty
straightforward
because now what
we can do is we can
start to look at how we compute
walks of length k, or k plus 1.
So let's first do the base case.
That's how we always start.
The base case is k equals 1.
And we have essentially
two options.
So we want to prove this,
so take an i and a j,
whatever you want.
So suppose we has an
edge, Vi, that goes to Vj.
Well in that case, we
know that the number
of walks of length
1, from i to j,
is exactly 1 because
there's this edge.
So this is equal to 1.
But this is also the definition
of my adjacency matrix.
So I can just write
out here aij 1.
So that's great.
This case definitely works.
Now, if there is no
edge of this type,
then you know that in one step,
we can never achieve Vj from Vi
because there's no edge.
So we know this is equal to 0.
There's no such walk.
And this is, by definition
of the adjacency matrix,
also equal to the aij.
So this works.
So the base case it's easy.
And induction step always
starts by issuing pk.
As you can see,
these types of proofs
always have the same structure.
In this case, let
me again assume pk.
We want to prove pk plus 1.
So what you want
to know is what's
the number of walks
of length k plus 1.
So how can we express those?
pij k plus 1.
How can we use this
assumption over here?
Do you have an idea so we can--
AUDIENCE: Any walk
of length k plus 1
can be got by taking one
of-- let's say from Vs
to Vx. [INAUDIBLE] You go
from Vs to V in k steps
and then V to Vf in one step.
PROFESSOR: That's true.
We could do that.
So let's write it down.
So what you're
essentially saying
is that you can
enumerate all the walks
by going of length k plus 1
by first going from i in, say,
k steps, to whatever
V, and then in one
step to, say, Vi to V in k steps
and then in one step to Vj.
So let's write this down
because V can be anything.
So what to do is we have
a sum over all the Vs
such that-- well, we
will use indices here
let me do that a
little bit differently.
So let's say I have
an h over here.
So all the indices
h such that Vh to Vj
is actually an edge in G.
So then we can write out here
that we go in k steps to Vh.
So how many walks are there?
Well, we can use the induction
hypothesis now, right?
So we can say you go
from i to h in k steps.
And then, well, we can
use this particular edge
to complete it to a k
plus 1th walk from i to j.
So now what is this equal to?
Can we simplify this sum?
We can, right, because
we know that there's
an edge if and only if the
adjacency matrix has a 1
in a particular position.
So we could rewrite it and
sum over all h from 1 to n.
And write pij k times, and then
aj-- oh, this should be an h.
So we have the same over here.
And then we have one
edge from h to 2j.
So I only count this number
over here if this is equal to 1,
and that happens exactly
if there's an edge.
I do not count this if
there's a 0 over here,
that is as if there's no edge.
But now we can use induction
hypothesis because I know that
these numbers are
equal to the a's.
So we rewrite this.
And we see that we get aih k.
So this is where we
use the induction step.
So it's like we
assume pk over here.
And I need to
finish this formula.
So we have this.
Now, by the definition
of matrix multiplication,
we actually see that this
is equal to a k plus 1 ij
to the ij-th entry in
the k plus oneth power
of the adjacency matrix.
Here we have this represents
the matrix of the kth power.
This represents the matrix of a.
So we multiply essentially
a to the power k times a
and get a to the power k plus 1.
And that's what we see here.
So this is the induction step,
and so this proves the theorem
up here.
So let's talk about a few
more definitions concerning
directed graphs.
And then you go a step
into a very special type
of graph, which are the
tournament graphs up here.
One of the things that
we have in undirected
graphs, so where we
have no directed edges,
we talked last time a lot about
cyclicity and stuff like that.
And we talked about
acyclic connected graphs.
And as we categorized those,
so we defined them as trees,
and they have a very
special structure.
So what would happen here, if
we look at a directed graph,
and we wonder, what does
it mean to be connected.
Can we really talk about that?
What does that mean?
For example, if I look at
this particular example
graph over here,
I can say, well,
V1 has an edge that
points towards V1 itself,
and towards V2, and towards V3.
So maybe I would call
this graph connected.
But if I look at V2,
I only see an edge
that goes from V2 to
V3, and not to V2.
So maybe I do not
call it connected.
So that's why we define a
stronger notion for a digraph.
So a digraph, G, VE is
called strongly connected
if we know that for every
pair-- so if for all vertices
U and V in the vertex
set-- there exists
a directed path that starts
in U and ends up in V in G.
So this is what we would
call strongly connected.
So now in undirected
graphs, we had connectivity
and then we said, well, if a
connected, undirected graph
has no cycles.
We have trees and they
have special properties
and all that.
So what about this over here?
Suppose you have an acyclic
strongly connected digraph.
What does that look like?
So let's give an example.
It's not completely clear
what kind of structure it has.
So for example, I
may have a graph that
looks like this, for example.
Say this is an acyclic graph.
but It does not have at
all a tree structure.
So actually, the type of
graph the we have here
is called a directed
acyclic graph.
As you can see,
there are no cycles
because I only go
forward, essentially.
I can never go backward
in this particular way
that I depicted the graph.
So this is an example for
directed acyclic graph.
But it doesn't look
like a tree at all.
So it's worth to
define it separately,
and we will use this
on Thursday when we'll
talk about partial orderings.
And it turns out that, as
you can see here-- well,
at that case, a
directed acyclic graph
has really nice
properties, and one of them
is that you can order these
vertices in such a way
that you go from, say, left to
right in a directed fashion.
And that will lead
to partial ordering.
So that's something that
we will talk about as well.
So what's the definition?
A directed graph is called
a directed acyclic graph,
and we appreciate this by DAG.
We call them DAGs.
They're used
everywhere, actually.
If it does not contain
any directed cycles.
So these kinds of
graphs are used
in scheduling and
optimization, and we
will use them next week in the
lecture on partial orderings.
Now we have done a
lot of definitions
concerning directed graphs.
So now let's talk about these
very special ones, tournament
graph, and see whether we
can prove a few really nice
theorems about them.
Let's see whether we can
figure that out together.
So what is a tournament graph?
In a tournament graph, I
have a bunch of vertices.
And essentially we want to
represent like a tournament.
So every vertex, say,
represents a team.
And a team can play
against another team,
and beat them or lose
against the other team.
So we want to use the
directed edges to indicate
who is winning from home.
And such types of graphs
have very special property.
So let me first depict one.
So for example, we have E
goes to A, goes through B,
incoming edge from
C, one coming from B.
And over here we have
this directed edge.
We have this one.
Let me see [INAUDIBLE] don't
make any mistakes here.
And this one.
And over here is another one.
So what do we see in this graph?
We see that either say,
team U, beats team V.
And that means that we have a
directed edge from U pointing
at V. Or it's other way around.
V actually beats U, and we have
a directed edge from V to U.
Let's have a look at this
graph and see how this works.
So for example, we have
that B is beating E,
and E is beating A, and so on.
So let's have a look.
Maybe we can figure out who's
the best player in here.
So this is sort of
a general question
if who would like to answer.
Maybe you cannot answer this.
So let's have an example.
Has anybody seen an example
where we start with A,
then we may beat another vertex,
and maybe another vertex,
and so on, until we have covered
all the different vertices.
Do you see a path
that works like that?
And that could gives
us an ordering on who
is the best player,
like the one at the top,
like A, is able to,
for example, beat B.
And B is, for example, able
to beat D and this one, E,
and this one, C. So you
would say, OK, that's great.
Now I know that this one
is the strongest player.
But there's a little
problem here, right?
Because I can produce
many such paths.
And actually, if I look at
C, then C beats A as well.
So that's kind of weird.
So wait a minute.
We have that there's a
directed edge from C to A.
It's like teams
beats one another.
And it's not very clear how we
can talk about a best player.
Well, we would
have a best player
if one player sort of
wins from everybody else.
But there's many examples here.
So let's look at another walk.
For example, C can go to B,
to D, and then to E, and then
to A. So there are many
possibilities here.
So this leads us to a concept.
And we call that's a
directed Hamiltonian path.
And we're going to show
that, in a tournament graph,
you can always find such a
directed Hamiltonian path.
So what's a Hamiltonian path?
This is actually
an example of it.
There's a walk that
goes around the graph
and visits every
vertex exactly once.
So we're going to prove
that a tournament graph has
this beautiful property.
So let's first write out
a definition of this.
A directed Hamiltonian
path is a directed walk
that visits every
vertex exactly once.
So as I said already, here
we have such an example.
We can go from A to B,
to D to E, to C. Maybe
there are even other examples.
I did not actually see them.
Maybe you can have a
look at them as well.
So maybe there's something that
starts with B going to E maybe.
That's a very different
direction, like this.
There will be one as
well, and so forth.
So what's the theorem
that you want to prove?
The theorem in that you want
to show that every tournament
graph actually contains such
a directed Hamiltonian path.
So let's have a look at
how we can prove this.
What kind of proof technique
are we going to use?
Do you have an idea?
Well, usually we use
induction so that's what
we're going to do here as well.
But what kind of induction
hypothesis can we do?
So what would we
induct on, you think?
Someone else?
Maybe someone up there?
AUDIENCE: The number of nodes.
PROFESSOR: The number of nodes.
So we use induction on
the number of nodes.
And why would that
be of interest?
So let's have a look at
how we can think of that.
So we start thinking about
such a problem, this really
sort of-- one parameter here
that's the number of nodes
in a tournament graph.
I also have edges.
But if I think about
edges, then, the edges
is always directly
related to the number
of nodes in a tournament graph.
So I really have just
that one parameter.
So it makes sense to use
induction on number of nodes.
So induct on n, where Pn
is going to be that every--
and essentially, the theorem
holds true for a tournament
graph on n nodes-- so every
tournament graph on n nodes
actually contains a
directed Hamiltonian path.
So this is semi
induction hypothesis.
So when you think
about that, well, I
feel pretty confident
because if I
look at the base case-- that's
how we always start-- well,
n equals 1.
If n equals 1, I have
just a single vertex.
There's no edges.
Everything is fine
because the single edge
is a directed Hamiltonian path.
So this is great.
So this works.
So what about inductive step?
Now with inductive
step, we always
perceived in the same way.
We start to assume
that Pn is true.
Essentially, the theorem
holds for a tournament graph
on n vertices.
Actually, let me
keep this over here.
So now let's just think about
how we can prove this induction
step.
I need to prove P of n plus 1.
So how do I start?
I have to start with
a tournament graph
on n plus 1 vertices.
And somehow I got to be
able to use this property
because that's what I assume.
And the property only holds
for a tournament graph
on end points.
So what will be a
really good strategy
to do here to sort
of proceed our proof?
So let me first write out
what we want to do here.
Maybe you can think about
how to advance here.
So we have shown Pn.
Now we want to actually
prove something
about tournament graphs
on n plus 1 nodes,
so let's consider one.
Consider a tournament
graph on n plus 1 nodes.
Now how can I use my
induction hypothesis?
So I start with this,
and I want to use
something that talks about the
tournament graph on n nodes.
So how could I proceed here?
Any suggestions?
So what do you
usually do, right?
If I have like an
n plus 1 nodes,
I have to somehow look
at least maybe there
exists a subgraph in
this bigger graph.
So this is really
how you always think
about these types of proofs
or also other problems.
So there must be
some kind of subgraph
that already has this property.
Well, let's take
out one node and see
what happens because then
we have one node less
and maybe we will be able
to apply our induction step.
So let's take out one node V.
And what can we say
about remaining graph
if we take out one node?
For example, if I take
out the node E over here
and I just look
at all the rest, I
can still see that for all
the other nodes either,
say, U beats V or V
beats U. So I still
have an edge in one direction
between each two nodes.
So actually I still
have a tournament graph,
so that's great.
So this gives a
tournament graph.
So essentially,
so far, we really
haven't done anything
creative or anything
that we had to make a big leap
in order to prove this theorem.
We started out with, if
you want to prove something
like this you have to really
look at the number of vertices.
And then we start to write
down this stuff over here
that makes total sense.
And then we are going
to figure out where
we can use this induction step.
And so we just
take out one node.
And yes, it is a tournament
graph on n nodes.
So this is very systematic.
That's what I try
to get at here.
So by the induction step because
by the induction hypothesis,
we know now that we actually
have a directed Hamiltonian
path.
So let V1 to V2 to
Vn be such a path.
So now that we can use this,
we apply it and we get a path.
Now what do we want to do?
We want to show that we can
create a new path, which
is also a directed Hamiltonian
path, but now one that also
includes V in the bigger graph.
If we can do that, we are done.
So now we have to
start really looking
at how we can make that happen.
In order to do this, we have
to see how we can somehow
plug V, the vertex
that we have removed,
in this path over here.
If you can do this, we
are in really good shape.
So far, we haven't used at
all-- so there's also something
that you can look
at if you start
solving these types of
problems-- we haven't used
at all the property that
the tournament graph has,
which I just wiped out.
So let's figure out
what we can do here.
We should be able
to use something.
So of course, we have
a few simple cases.
For example, if V has a
directed edge into V1,
and I have a Hamiltonian path
that goes from V to V1 to V2
all the way to Vn, and then I
cover all the vertices exactly
once.
And I will have a
direct Hamiltonian path.
So this is great.
So this is definitely easy.
So this is case one.
In case two, suppose that
V1 has a directed edge to V.
And So now we have a little
problem because somehow there
is an edge like this to V,
but they cannot go like this.
This is not a Hamiltonian path.
I need to have a
directed walk that covers
all the vertices exactly once.
So now we have a little problem.
So now we have to
start really thinking
about how we can solve this.
So are there any suggestions
to make this happen?
So let's think a
little bit about this.
So somehow if I start
thinking about this,
I would like to plug V
somewhere in this sequence.
That will be like a pretty
obvious way to-- go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's true.
So for example, I may
have that for example,
V2 beats V as well.
But suppose that I have V3 over
here, and this one beats V3.
Then, as you say, I could
sort of plug V in here
in this sequence and I may
have a longer sequence.
Or if this is not the case,
then maybe the next one, V4,
may have the property
and I can plug V in here.
So essentially what I want
to show is that I can plug V
somewhere in the middle
of two of these Vi's.
And the property
that you were using
is actually that you said,
well, I know that V2 either
beats V, or V beats V2.
So that's the property
of the tournament graph
that we're going to use
here in order to prove this.
So yes, that's a
great observation.
So the way you formulated it,
we can maybe use induction,
for example, to prove this.
We can sort of go
recursively through this
until you find the right spot.
Maybe they can immediately
precisely indicate such a spot.
So how do we usually do that?
If we are thinking
about other theorems
that we have tried to prove.
AUDIENCE: What's the
smallest value of i
such that V beats Vi?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So what's the smallest
value of i where V beats Vi.
So usually we have words in our
mind like largest or smallest,
et cetera, and sort of
an extreme precision.
And then we like to find out
that we can make it happen.
And then we say, well,
if something goes wrong,
we violate that
smallest condition.
So let's do that here.
So let's indicate
a specific spot.
Let's considered the smallest
i such that V beats Vi.
Well, let's have a look
how this would work.
So this is a little bit
of a different proof
than what I had but this
should work fine as well.
So let's just see how it works.
So we have V1.
First of all, we notice that,
of course, if i equals 1,
which that cannot be the case,
so we know that i is larger
than 1.
So there's really
somewhere a Vi minus 1--
we have to check that, right?
If that exists,
this index is not
equal to zero-- that goes to
Vi and then goes all the way up
to Vn.
So now we say we can use this,
that V actually beats Vi.
Now what's about-- maybe
someone else can help me here--
I would like to
have that Vi minus 1
beats V. That would be fantastic
because then I have a path that
goes from V1 all
the way up here,
goes here, goes there, and
all the way up to here.
So we have a directed
Hamiltonian path
that covers all the
vertices exactly once,
and that's what
you want to prove.
But why would there be an
edge that goes this way?
So how do we reason about this?
Someone else?
AUDIENCE: Because Vi is the
smallest number that V beats,
then anything smaller
than i must have beat V.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So if V would beat
Vi minus 1, that
would contradict the
smallest property over here.
So that's a contradiction.
Now we use a property
of the tournament graph.
So now I know that Vi
minus 1 must beat V.
So I really have
an edge over here.
So that works.
So that's the end of the proof.
Now another version
could have been
in which we would do
something similar like this.
But we could also
have used, say,
the largest i-- just something
that you may want to look at.
You can also use
the largest i such
that Vi beats V. We have a
completely symmetrical argument
here, but you could use
this solution as well.
So I'm just trying
to sketch here
the way of thinking that
you may want to consider
in these types of problems.
So why would this
work, by the way?
Well, we have the same
kind of argument like this.
We plug V right after Vi.
We know there's an edge
from V to Vi plus 1.
Why?
If it's not the case, there
will be a large index, i,
that contradicts our
assumption that we
have the largest i already.
It's a tournament graph,
so we know that there's
an edge from V to Vi plus 1.
And we get a directed
Hamiltonian path as well.
So you may want to
look at that as well.
So this is about
tournament graphs.
So let's talk about an
interesting tournament graph
with a funny game.
And this is actually
a chicken tournament,
like the chickens here
represent the vertices
and they are pecking one
another, but in a certain rule
that defines a chicken
to be the king chicken.
So let's see how that works.
So that's a great
application of graph theory.
So what do we have?
We have that either a chicken,
U, pecks a chicken, V.
And we said that U has
a direct edge to V,
so we're actually defining
a tournament graph here.
Or we have a chicken, V,
that pecks a chicken, U,
and we get V has a
direct edge to U.
So we have a tournament graph.
But now we define something new.
We say that U virtually pecks
V if one of the two conditions
holds-- one of these two
conditions-- either U,
of course, pecks
V. That's great.
He's in good shape.
Or there exists another
chicken, W, such
that U actually pecks
W and W, in turn,
pecks V. So this is very special
kind of first relationship.
So we are wondering now can
we now define something--
is there a question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
in between?
To be virtually
pecked, is one chicken
in between U and the other one?
PROFESSOR: Well, there
can be multiple chickens
in between here.
I have several friends who help
me out pecking someone else.
So when we were looking at
these tournament graphs,
we were wondering, can we really
indicate a winning player?
Well in this case, if you start
to talk about virtual pecking,
we look at the pecking order.
Then we can actually define
something like a chicken king.
So let me write that down.
Let me first explain
what I mean here.
And I give an
example of a graph.
So a chicken that is able
to virtually peck everyone
else, we will call a king.
So chicken that virtual
pecks every other chicken
is called a king chicken.
So let's give an
example of a graph.
So, for example, suppose
I have four chickens that
know how to pick one
another in this order.
So who in the pecking party
here is going to be king?
Do you see some solutions here?
So take, for example, this one.
So this one pecks this one.
Because we talk about
virtually pecking,
it can also peck
this one over here.
It does, right?
It pecks this one and this
one helps out, and can peck
both this one and this one.
That's cool.
So this one is king.
And this one, actually--
let's have a look.
It pecks this one this
one, and it virtually
also pecked this one.
Yay.
He has a friend over here
that is doing that for him.
So this one is
actually also a king.
So you can have multiple
king chickens in here.
What about this one?
The same story-- pecks
this one, pecks this one,
and virtually-- wait a minute.
The one on the left--
oh yeah, over here.
This, this.
So this one is king as well.
Now what about this one?
Well, it can peck this one.
And then in one
more step from here,
because there's only
one outgoing edge,
it can virtually peck this
one, but not this one.
So this one is definitely
the loser of the four.
So he's not the king.
So now what we want to
prove this a theorem
sort of trans-identify
one of the chickens
that we know for sure
is going to be king.
So you can have multiple kings.
But maybe there's one chicken
that, from our intuition,
we may feel is definitely
going to be king.
So what will be
a good intuition?
So we're talking here
about virtual pecking.
We have this definition.
So what kind of node
in a tournament graph
essentially would be-- can we
know for sure that it's a king?
Do you have an
intuition for a theorem
that you may want to prove?
So that's often what
we do in mathematics.
We have some kind of
funny new structure,
and then we want to
find out whether we
can prove interesting
properties about it.
So we start to search for actual
nice properties and theorems.
So in this case, it makes
sense that the vertex
that has the most outgoing
edges may be always king.
Can we prove this?
So that's what
we're going to do.
So that's the theorem.
And let's see whether we can
do this in an elegant way.
So the theorem is
that even though there
are multiple
kings-- as indicated
in that particular
example, that may happen--
but I certainly know that the
chicken that has the highest
outdegree is definitely a king.
And the way we're going to
prove this is by contradiction.
Let's assume that's
not the case.
That must be really,
really weird.
If you are the one who
has the largest outdegree,
it means that you can
directly, just by yourself,
peck the most others.
So suppose you're not king.
So by contradiction,
first of all,
let U have the
highest outdegree.
And we want to show
that this U is king.
So let's assume the contrary.
So let's suppose
that U is not king.
So what does that mean?
So let's look at a
definition over there
and see what it means
that U is not king.
So that means that both
those conditions are violated
because if one of
those two holds,
I know there must
be one vertex, V,
such that U does not virtually
peck V. So I know that.
So let's see what that implies.
So I know that there
must be a V such
that U does not virtually peck
V. So maybe can help me out.
What does that mean?
It means that both these
conditions are not true.
So let's look at the first.
So U pecks V. If
that's not true,
and we're in the
tournament graph,
we know that V must
peck U. So we have this.
and we also know that the
other condition, the second one
over here, does not hold.
So what's the negation
of this second condition?
Maybe you can help me out.
So we have here, there
exists a W such that U pecks
W and W pecks V. So how do we
negate that logical expression?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: For all W, what's
over there is not through true.
So can we formulate that
a little bit better?
So it's not true that U pecks
W and W pecks V. So that
means that either U
pecks W is not true,
or W pecks V is not true.
So let's write that down.
Let's just write it all out.
So not U pecks W or
not W pecks V. Well,
how can we rewrite this?
Well, it's a
tournament graph, so we
know that W pecks U. Or this
particular condition, which
is V pecks W.
So what do I have here?
Is this going in
the right direction?
Well, I want to prove something
about-- if I use contradiction
and I suppose that
U is not the king,
I've assumed that U has
the highest outdegree.
So I want to show that
I somehow violated.
So somehow I'm able to
construct some vertex, V.
And by negating
that U is not a king
it seems that this vertex, V,
makes a really good candidate
to show that there's a higher
degree outdegree than U.
So let's see whether
we can do this.
We can rewrite this logical
expression once more.
We can also say that, well,
if U pecks W-- so this
is not true-- then
it must be true
that this one holds because
if that's not the case,
then this condition is not true.
So if U pecks W, then
this is not true.
So then it must be the
case that that is true.
So V pecks W. So now
let's have a look at V.
We noticed that for all
outgoing edges from U,
there exists a similar
outgoing edge for V.
But V has one more
outgoing edge.
V, actually, is an
outgoing edge to U.
So what do we see here?
That the outdegree of V is
actually at least the outdegree
of U-- which is this
particular condition over here
that we show here,
for all the W we
have that this is true-- plus
and we have an extra one.
It's this one.
Oh, but now we have
a contradiction
because we said that U
has the highest degree.
But it turns out that
you have constructed one
that has a higher outdegree.
So that's a contradiction.
That means that our original
assumption is actually wrong.
So suppose that U is not the
king was a wrong assumption,
and U must be king.
So that's the end of this proof.
This is the end of this lecture.
So see you tomorrow
at recitation
and next week we will continue
with communication graphs
and partial orderings.